ينضم الينا من جنوب روسيا مدير مكتب
الجزيره زاور شاوج زاور نبدا من اخر
المستجدات واي دلالات يحمل
اضاءه صليب على مبنى فاغنر في سنه بيتر
سبورتا
نعم في البدايه على الهيئه الطيران
الفيدراليه الروسيه عن انتشار جثث جميع
الركاب الذين مدونه اسمائهم على الاقل في
القوائم وعددهم عشره في الطائره المنكوبه
وانه تم نقلهم الى مستشفى مدينه توفير
عاصمه مقاطعه المقاطعه واعلى تهيئه
الطيران ايضا عن انتهاء اعمال البحث عن
الجثث وطبعا في وقت متزامن تقوم هيئه
التحقيقات الفيدراليه الروسيه بالتعاون مع
وزاره الطوارئ وهيئه الطيران الفيدراليه
بالتحقيقات
والانتشال الادله فيما يتعلق بحيثيات حادث
تحطم هذه الطائره طبعا كما ذكرت هيئه
الطيران الفيدراليه اسم
والقائد العسكري لقوات فاجنرلد
موجود ضمن القوائم قوائم الاشخاص العشره
الذين علامه الطائره هناك معلومات متضاربه
كثيره معظمها ليس من مصادر رسميه مصادر
تعتمد على تصريحات من قوات فاجنر او
مقربين من قوات تؤكد مصرع اوتكن وبريغوجين
في تحطم هذه الطائره دون ان تعطي اي
تاكيدات حول شكل
تحطم هذا هذه الطائره هل كان هل استهدفت
بصاروخ امانه انفجرت في الجو ام هناك عطل
فني وتقني تبقى هذه القضيه في مستوى
التحقيقات التي تقوم بها الاجهزه المعنيه
في روسيا اما فيما يتعلق باضاءه الصلبان
على مبنى او مباني شركه كونكورد هذه
الشركه التي هي فعليا الغطاء والواجهه
لشركات
رجل الاعمال هي دلاله على نوع من الحداد
اطفاء كل الانوار وابقاء عدد قليل من
الاضواء على شكل صليب هنا في روسيا يرمز
الى نوع من الحداد لدى المسيحيين
الارثوذكس هنا وهم الغالبيه كما نعلم في
روسيا طبعا فيما يتعلق بالمواقف الرسميه
غائبه تماما فداء لحد الان لا يوجد اي
موقف في هكذا حدث يعتبر جلل بالنسبه
لروسيا شخصيه ليست بالقليله شخصيه مهمه
جدا شخصيه كانت مثيره للجدل في الاشهر
الاخيره اقصد هنا
طبعا اضافه الى ان الانظار كلها متجهه
الان الى البيان المنتظر من قاده او من
المجلس العسكري للقياده العسكريه لقوات
فاقدر الذي على ما يبدو سيعلن على الاقل
بحسب ما يصلنا من معلومات سيعلن عن مقتل
بريغوجين واوتين وشخصيات اخرى مقربه من
علامات هذه الطائره هناك اسئله كثيره
متعلقه ايضا بالطائره الثانيه التي ايضا
اقلعت
هناك حديث كثير عن انفاق انتهت انا دور
فايندر في روسيا انتهى ولكن يبدو انه يعني
الحكم يبدو مبكرا الان بعد مقتل ان ثبت
مكتب ريجوجن عن مستقبل فاقدر الذي اكتمل
على روسيا فقط
تاكيد الرئيس الروسي